yeah okay we're going to get started
we're going to get started my mic is my
mic everyone hear me waiting for the
gentleman to give me a thumbs up okay so
welcome to the ohsu department of
medical informatics and clinical
epidemiology seminar we are thrilled
today to have Lori coiner with us and
this is being streamed so if you want to
send us a tweet for those of you out in
the world you can do that by sending it
to at ohsu informatics you can put a
hashtag but we'll follow it if you want
to use the hashtag de maiz conf conf
then we are happy to see those as well
but at ohsu informatics so I'm David
door I'm the vice chair of clinical
informatics in the department and
associate professor here and this is a
topic that's very near and dear to my
heart in a lot of ways so this is a
great sort of way to think about the way
that informatics is affecting a lot of
our healthcare and healthcare reform and
we're thrilled to have Lloyd Lloyd
corner here today who is the director of
accountability and quality at the Oregon
Health Authority so she sits in the
director's office and reports to the
director and really focuses on all the
aspects of health reform that have to do
with quality quality measurement quality
improvement so she's going to talk a
little bit about what's going on in that
world with the coordinated care
organizations and all of the different
aspects meaningful use that our health
information exchange that are happening
there and then I'm going to talk a
little bit about an infirmity shins view
of this sort of it from the work we do
at ohsu and as informatics with how we
think about advancing this work based on
what the health reform is bringing
so Laurie thank you for those of you
who've been around the informatics world
for a little while my game was formerly
Laurie Lambert night taught the
introduction to a biostatistics for a
lot of years for this program we're on
the mph program so my name's change the
same person same poor jokes so I I
wanted to check are you going to be
advancing slides or should I just do it
from here okay I can do it um the title
of my talk today is where's Oregon where
Oregon's health system transformation
meets informatics what we're going to
what I'm going to go through today is
kind of I'm coping a little bit of a
stepwise talk so I'm going to give you a
little overview about what health system
transformation is from the health
authorities perspective then what
measurements we need to do to measure
whether that's working and then how
those then relate to the h i thi e
strategy that the state's working toward
and then David's going to get down into
some details about where where that gets
complicated so the health system
transformation was first thought through
by our governor john his kids huh / and
the Health Authority started by
developing what are called C cos that's
coordinated care organizations and the
model of those has been described as a
CEOs or accountable care organizations
on steroids so how and the reason I
think for that is that we have a very
fast implementation plan they were the
first ccos came into existence in 2012
late-2012 and the first year that we're
tracking with measurement is 2013 but to
think a little bit about what the model
is like there it's there's a big push to
integrate services so rather than this
kind of old-fashioned managed care
organizations that just focused on
physical health mental health services
are now rolled in and dental is being
rolled in on in January and July so now
these coordinated
care organizations will be responsible
for mental health services physical
health services and dental services for
their clients and they're given one
global budget to do that the global
budget will grow at a fixed rate each
year so they know how much they're
getting next year and they need to
operate within that budget however
they're given lots of flexibility on how
to do that there's work on we have line
items for flexible services for example
so someone we heard from a CCO that had
a patient who was on down in southern
part of the state he broke his leg he
was living out in a trailer far from any
services poor nutrition not clean they
were going to amputate so the CCO found
out about it they paid for housing they
paid for him to move into town and get
regular services and some nursing visits
that kind of care is what's being
promoted so that housing service doesn't
get dumped into administrative costs
it's put in as a line item of flexible
services so we're trying to change the
what the model is of health care so and
add for local flexibility then the key
component and the major piece that I'm
going to talk about is this metrics over
there the orange box on and the they're
serving two purposes one is that we the
state is on the hook with CMS to UM show
that we are not degrading quality but in
fact improving it over time and then the
other purpose of the metrics is to pay
the CCOs based on their performance on
incentive metrics I this map wasn't
intended to be able to read all the CCOs
but it's just to show you where they are
there are 15 of them the darker green
shaded area show you where there's more
than one cc o some o SP members have an
opportunity to sign up for one or the
other but a good portion of the state
there's only one and Eastern Oregon CCO
covers I can't remember how many square
miles but it's huge and it's mostly
rural providers so they really vary in
terms of their service population and
what their delivery system looks like
um here are the main tenants on then
that we when we made the negotiation
with CMS that we are on the hook for so
the first is to reduce the annual
increase of the cost of care by 2
percentage points a year on while we do
that we need to ensure that quality
improves on population health improves
we have established that what's called a
one-percent withhold that is the CCOs
are paid that one percent when they
report their claims in a timely manner
and that has partly to do with our
ability to measure the claims are coming
in a year late then it they kind of miss
out on our quality measurement and and
then to establish this quality pool and
the methodology by which will pay on the
incentive metrics so we had to develop a
quality and accountability plan this is
the part that I oversee and it was part
of the 1.9 billion dollar agreement that
was made with CMS for this health system
transformation one is a quality strategy
so that tells how we're going to improve
quality the state test for quality and
access is 33 measures that we need to
track over time we actually have an
independent entity calculating those
quality core and they then on we start
losing funds if we either for the first
two years we have to keep quality the
same then we have to start showing
improvement and the state will lose
funding from the federal government if
we don't show those improvements over
time on we have a detailed measurement
strategy and then this quality pool
incentive payment program um the kind of
tenants around this we have a
transformation Center which is housed in
OHA it has innovator agents that are
embedded in each of the CCOs um it's
built on the model of Agricultural
Extension where they're experts they
come back together and discuss issues
this the CCOs are having and try to
spread best practices they all the
transformation is all center and my
office or dip
learning collaborative which are focused
mostly on peer-to-peer learning and
rapid cycle improvement each of the CCOs
is required to have a Community Advisory
Council made up of patients and members
on there's an approach to add
non-traditional healthcare workers which
means lay health workers in and figure
out ways to get them paid and then
there's a real emphasis on
patient-centered primary care home
adoption um so the 33 metrics that I
talked about we those are the metrics
that were on we need to show maintenance
and an improvement of quality and then
they fall under these seven focus areas
so the first and I mentioned this
earlier is an integration of behavioral
and physical health um because the
population is primarily women and
children there's a focus on improving
perinatal and maternity care um reducing
preventable rehospitalizations ensuring
appropriate care is delivered in an
appropriate setting improving primary
care for all populations there's one
focus area on high-cost patients or high
utilizers we have a collaborative on
what we call complex care patients on
and then finally focus on some chronic
disease such as diabetes and
hypertension so I said there was a big
measurement strategy on the 33
performance measures are the state test
m and quality and access measures 16 of
those are also the incentive measures so
we do have overlap there's one
additional of the incentive measures
that the CMS wasn't interested in but we
thought was important we also have six
core performance 16 core performance
measures that we on have to report to
CMS they are what I consider a bit more
transformational than some of the other
measures they include on rate of
contraceptive use for women not desiring
pregnancy BMI on tobacco use and some
things like that where we're really
working and thinking about how to
collect and report
and then we have to CMS grants the
chipra for children and a medicated
quality corset that we're reporting as
part as those grants and then we have
over a hundred measures that we have to
report to the US Department of Justice
for patients with severe and persistent
mental illness so how did we come up
with our incentive measures on we the
Senate established a metrics of scoring
committee and this committee met a lot
to the fall of 2012 and came up with a
measurement strategy and four on what
measures would be in the quality pool
and how that quality pool gets
distributed I'm not going to spend a lot
of time talking about this if people are
interested we do have the whole quality
pool methodology posted online and i can
send david a link to that but it was a
multi stakeholder group they worked with
an outside consultant came up with who
recommended less than 20 measures for a
pay-for-performance program and came up
with 17 and then they came up with this
quality pool strategy i guess though the
quick things i'll tell you about it it's
on considered a bridge strategy from
moving from capitated payments to
payments for outcomes though most all
the measures are processed measures and
not outcome measures the idea is that
the metrics and scoring committee which
is still meeting on every other month we
examine the measures kind of look at
progress on highlight difficulties
adjust benchmarks on and eventually hope
to move to outcome measures the pool
size is based on two percent of each of
the CCOs p.m. p.m. so in terms of what
they're billed charges are and then it's
distributed based on enrollment and kind
of a pass/fail on the measure so each
measure is weighted equally they either
get a pass fail how do they pass they
either meet or exceed the benchmark
which is usually than seventy fifth or
90th percentile nash for medicaid
nationally or they meet an improvement
target and this
idea of a concept of an improvement
target has turned out to be a very a
good deal and it's developed on a
methodology that was um first started in
the state of Minnesota and it's based on
where each CCO starts their gap to the
benchmark and basically it's pretty
simple you just measure that gap / 10
and that's the proportion that they need
to increase each year or improve each
year to meet their on performance target
the idea was that you know that C cos if
you saw a geographical distribution and
the delivery system differences there's
going to be huge variation and so on the
idea is that if each CCO meets their
improvement target within 10 years
they'll be exceeding the fence benchmark
so I here are the list of measures um
you can look at the slides I'm not going
to walk through all of them we have
quite a few that are related to
behavioral health but the first one
screening for clinical depression and
follow-up well let me take an aside so I
took this job almost exactly a year ago
and I had this list of measures and so
we've spent a big portion of time
operationalizing those because if it
just says alcohol a drug misuse
screening brief intervention and
referral per treatment that's a process
called often known as expert but then
the whole question came oh how do we
measure it what do we measure it's a
completely new idea we didn't have
national standards for it and we had 17
of these to figure out so screening for
clinical depression and follow-up plan
at first we thought we'd follow claims
we opened up some codes in our Medicaid
billing and then a lot of people just
said this wasn't going to work across
payer so um it's now a measure that we
are going to be collecting through
electronic medical records that's why
it's highlighted because we're going to
focus on that we have a number of
measures around maternal and child
health have different stages of age and
then we have two other measures that are
highlighted optimal diabetes care and
controlling hyper
mention that those two comprise with the
clinic with the depression screening
comprised the three that we will be on
having reported through electronic
medical records rather than claims so
when I came a year ago also the agency
had planned to do old-fashioned chart
review for these on the cost was huge it
was upwards of a million dollars a year
to get 15 numbers reach you know 15
times three numbers and we'd have to do
that every year and you just end up with
a number so that the thinking was if
we're going to be investing funds into
on collecting the data why not try to
build something that's going to be
moving towards electronic medical record
reporting than just doing sending people
out to do chart review every year so
once we started to work on that path we
I started to work closely with Susan
otter who's the director for a chai tea
hie within the state and a lot more of
what I'm going to talk about is related
to to that we also have some appropriate
access measures emergency department use
you may have read the article in science
we're measuring ed use on as we go now
and then a patient experience measuring
and one that's a measure of electronic
record health record adoption which CMS
felt strongly that we need to create
some sort of measure of that so what is
the strategy to collect and report these
metrics this is at the CCO level we've
really had to think what are we going to
do and how are we going to do it and um
the idea came I guess in three main with
three main thoughts one of them is to
face it in overtime we know that um
Eastern Oregon CCO for example still has
a lot of practices with patient with
paper-based records on we know that the
Portland metro area has a lot of highway
EHR adoption level but the problem is
that their network is huge so on what we
decided is we'd face
this process in overtime and and link it
with the building of our a chai tea
strategy on the second thing is we know
that the meaningful use stage 2
standards are out that on electronic
medical record vendors need to put the
meaningful use stage 2 capabilities into
their EHRs this year and so we want to
leverage that and the fact that we
collect we are going to have to collect
data from those providers who want to
meet meaningful use stage 2 for Medicaid
and then the third thing as I mentioned
we felt that there was a new push to
develop a statewide hie HIV strategy so
that we needed to couple the this
collection of EHR data with the strategy
so when I said we were going to phase it
in we had to go back to CMS and
negotiate this on and so what's the plan
well what we decided was for 2013 year
payments for ccos on instead of paying
for performance on diabetes and
depression screening we would just pay
for measurement reporting so they have
technology plans that are due februari
first that describe their network
describe their gaps and opportunities
and how they're going to collect a safe
of concept sample that proof of concept
sample only needs to be 10 represent ten
percent of their membership on then in
2014 they'll need to update their
technology plans and talk about how they
worked on their gaps that's really what
we're going to be focusing on and then
um require them to send us an expanded
set of data we haven't really determined
what that's going to be until we've had
a chance to learn more about what's
going on through their technology plans
and then on the part where we really had
to negotiate with CMS's they were not
completely okay with two full years of
only pay for reporting so what we said
is you get your quality pool funds if
you
or if you want to be included in this
face too we have a challenge pool that's
kind of leftover funds because we're
committed to distributing everything so
for the challenge pool if you are you
know turned in your data then we will
look at some kind of performance metric
and we have to build that we have to
determine benchmarks and we're working
on that now and then finally by 2015 we
would be expecting full data reporting
and then paying for performance be on
full the reason I have it in quotes
there is I don't anticipate that we'll
be asking ccos to to get all the data
from all of their providers so we're
going to have to come up with some
sampling strategy that we have not
figured out yet so just to give you
everyone an ID on an overview so what
does this H i thi e strategy look like
on this is what we're calling the near
term or phase one point five of the
development on and it has kind of a
collection of pieces the one that were
most focused on for the quality measures
is this building of a clinical quality
metrics registry so the by 2015 when
people have to report their full data
set we will have a catcher's mitt on
which is called the clinical quality
metrics registry to collect all the data
on the other pieces that are included in
the 1.5 strategy include a provider
directory that has going to have a lot
of different functions and capabilities
Hospital notifications what that means
is that the patient arrives in the ER
that that someone you know their primary
care providers notified there's
technical assistance that we are going
to be paying for we'll be putting out an
RFP for that to help um providers meet
meaningful use stage 2 and and probably
learn how to submit their metrics into
the clinical quality metrics registry
that registry is kind of a twofer for us
they we can we will be collecting
information either
from ccos or providers on ccos behalf on
for the CCO measurement but also that
will be the vehicle by which providers
submit to get their meaningful use stage
2 payments for medicaid so we have to
build that anyway for the Medicaid
meaningful use portion so we decided to
put it together and then on there's
still a push for statewide direct secure
messaging and a patient on index and as
you can see it says 2013 2 2015 we need
to have that metrics registry developed
and built by 2015 in order to collect
information from the CCOs so um this
just shows kind of how the whole
strategy is going to work we we do
expect that the clinical metrics
database will require some kind of data
intermediary potentially that we collect
the data and maybe just send us the
Medicaid on we have to still adopt
standards for safety privacy and
security which um it's causing us to
really think about and I think David
will talk a little bit more about this
we're looking at having on for example
practices commit submit what's called QR
da formats there's QR da one which is
that the patient level there's QR da 3
which is a numerator and denominator for
the practice we would prefer in the long
term to get QR da one but then you have
to work your way through a lot of
privacy and security issues on and then
again we plan to align the metrics and
reporting um this just shows you that we
do we are collecting and making payments
on Medicaid on this is where the state
of Oregon stands as of fall of 2013 on
Medicare is paid about 3,200 providers
and 29 hospitals in Oregon and Medicaid
so the state agency has paid 1,700
providers and 50 hospitals hospitals for
those of you who are not steeped in
meaningful use hospitals can apply for
both
Medicaid and Medicare providers have to
select one and this just shows you a map
as of it was last updated at the end of
June on EHR adoption or health record
incentive programs within the state and
who where the eligible providers for
Medicare payments are so you can see
it's not evenly distributed across the
state the light colors have less
adoption the dark darker colors have
more the dots or hospitals so you can
see out in Easter that light color
almost completely maps to the Eastern
Oregon CCO um and then this is just in a
summary of EHR adoption in the state um
it's actually we're quite high for the
country um and that's one thing that
we're really why we think we can
leverage this approach on I do want to
mention in terms of our technology plans
we are allowing ccos if they have it
some of them have local H IES they could
submit that way we have kind of an
alternate on format that they can submit
if they have a large clinical registry
instead of that straight out of EHRs so
we're trying to develop that capability
as well because we are aware that not
everyone's got full EHR adoption um and
so as I mentioned some of the gaps so
geographic areas are very and the other
piece that's going to be real
challenging for us in the long term is
that being you'll you may remember at
the beginning of when I started talking
EHR providers I mean I'm see CEOs need
to integrate physical health mental
health services but behavioral health
providers on have very very low EHR
adoption rate as do long-term care
facilities so that's going to have to be
a long-term goal um so here are some
opportunities and I don't know if now is
a good time David to talk about this but
I have spoken with David about
opportunities for students who are
looking for internships and so here's a
brainstorm of a couple the first one on
so I i mentioned that we're going to be
providing ta services for people meeting
meaningful use stage 2 and and for
helping practices submit data and in
order to put that together and figure
out what kind of ta people need we plan
to take a hard look at the technology
plans that are being submitted februari
first and then we've also found out that
most of the CCOs or at least many of
them have been on sending out surveys of
their provider networks and we were we
are going to ask them if they'd be
willing to share will compile the
information and send it back out but we
think that between the surveys and the
technology plans we can learn a lot
about where the state of the state in
terms of reporting on these clinical
measures where that stands and where the
gaps are and so that's an area where we
think a student could come in and and
take a look at all of it compile it and
then you know make some statements about
or help us identify gaps and
opportunities for technical assistance
the other thing there is is lots of
thinking that needs to be done around
privacy and security we've had a number
of conversations with other states in
the country who are doing this
Connecticut for example is moving
towards that QR da one or patient level
on most of the states are starting with
numerators denominators in their in
their collection their catcher's mitt
and then they plan to move to QR da one
but thinking about the fact that when a
provider submits data it does not parse
out payer type so medicaid's in there
with commercial how do we make
adjustments for that how do we think
about privacy and security for
collecting information from commercial
do we need a data intermediary things
like that and then the last is the a
more details and helping us learn more
details around
the use of the QR da and CCDA formats
what the what the opportunities are what
the challenges are so that when we write
our materials and start expecting people
to submit that we have a good
understanding of what the limitations
are so um I think that's all I have
David now come can address further some
of the challenges around collecting the
data just real quickly here's my contact
information if you have questions Susan
otters on who is overseeing the h i thi
e strategy and then also that link up
there is our metrics page it has all of
the specifications for every metrics the
quality pool methodology and probably
more than you'd ever want to know Thanks
och briefly and then I'll actually put
this slide up and then we'll have a
question and answers isn't the
microphone okay okay great so let me
switch to
so as you heard there is an incredible
amount going on and there is especially
for health information exchange and
getting the clinical quality measures
getting actually down to the patient
level details so they can collect this
and really understand clinically what's
going on with these patients and the
care that's being delivered from that
perspective is really advancing quickly
this this has been an issue for a long
time that we've based our clinical
quality measures either on chart review
or on administrative claims billing
which in that sense the date is really
collected for a much different purpose
it's to generate a bill to justify that
you saw a particular patient in an
office visit and in a mostly
fee-for-service system you're really
just trying to say i had this office
visit I saw this patient here's here's
why and there's not much not as much
that's specifically tied to the quality
as we think about clinicians now so I'm
going to talk about this I have sort of
multiple frames of reference that I'm
going to try to use one is sort of as an
implementation what do we think about
the scanners and vocabulary what do we
think about health information exchange
what are some of the issues that come
out of this where are the opportunities
but also I play a role here in the sort
of clinical operations at ohsu what's
our experience in like trying to look at
some of these standards for the health
information exchange for ascending
electronic clinical quality measures for
meeting meaningful use for participating
in our particular CCO which is prank
although we get patients I think from
every single CCO all 15 because ohsu is
has so much complex carrot delivers that
um what's our experience in working with
our CCO and the quality of care as
reflected back to us as we really think
about how do we deliver the best
possible care that we can and have that
reflected in the measures that we send
and where do we need to go
across that so health information
exchange I think is a really simple and
it turns out the electronic clinical
quality measure formats really fit into
this they're really just you know from
an informatics perspective there's
collecting all the data about the
quality you receive but really it's
what's happened is that you've started
we've started to define standards to
stage that data to send it out and and
there's a broad standard around that but
the goal is really at transitions of
care when you're reflecting the care
you've given to a population of patients
who might need a particular quality
measure that you're getting the right
data to the right person at the right
time through the right channel much like
clinical decision support which is more
just in time right as you're seeing the
patient this is sort of as somebody is
thinking about this population or this
individual patient at a transition or at
to reflect the mackeir that's been
delivered for performance what's
happening or what happened and so
historically we've struggled to sort of
implement health information exchange
there's lots of value propositions here
when we look at some of the CCO measures
readmission risk can that be mitigated
if we send out this ADT the admission
information when somebody shows up to an
emergency department hospitalization out
to the primary care provider and they
can get that right just in time and
maybe prevent a hospitalization mark
frizzy when he worked in their health
information exchange and Memphis he
showed that there was a value-added in
terms of reduction in cost when ed
physicians had that right information
were able to communicate they could say
you know I feel safe not admitting this
person to the hospital but sending them
home instead with good follow-up and so
there's some real value that can come
but it hasn't spread Indianapolis has
done this for a long time really the
whole state of Indiana now sharing
information trying to figure out how we
can better use information to make good
clinical decisions about individual
patients and populations and so finally
sort of the country is catching up you
know there's lots of things going on now
but these standards have evolved so
rapidly from an informatics perspective
that it's very difficult to figure out
what's going on i'll show you you know
in some ways the early adopters might be
a little penalized now because you've
got to rear etro fit what you did but
we're all the good part about is now we
can sort of have a standard we can rely
on and and and send out so I'm going to
give a bunch of examples around this and
I'll sort of go through them there's a
lot of acronyms tons of acronyms you
coordinated care organizations you heard
about so I'm going to try and define
mine up front and I'll say right away
the first to ccr and CTD are basically
all but dead ccda has become so
basically what we were trying to define
as is sort of informatics as sort of
people who are interested in exchanging
data here is what is the core set of
data that's needed what's the format
that we could send it that's a standard
that can go across to different places
so it could be understood by somebody
who needs to think about this patient at
a transition and as its evolved across a
set of patients as population and so
there was the continuity of care record
that was defined and then the continuity
of care document that sort of tapped
into hl7 s clinical document
architecture and then finally and really
it's about 2011-2012 we we've got this
consolidated clinical document
architecture CCDA and it turns out
though you know you can define standards
all you want right but will this
standard get taken up in a meaningful
way what are the motivators for this
obviously health policy an opportunity
is one but the the the sort of utility
to providers and utility to the the
institution the value that it adds and
going through the step of implementing
the standard and and being able to
receive it is really important a lot of
the potential a lot of the initial step
of the foundation has been pushed to EHR
vendors as as mentioned EHR vendors are
now required for certification to have
this functionality but
a lot of the really where the rubber
meets the road is implementation and so
we'll talk a little bit about that and
it turns out that the way we're talking
about sending the electronic quality
measures either the aggregate of the
patient level electronically for
Meaningful Use for others that that Lori
mentioned is through this specific kind
of a CCDA called a QR da the Quality
Reporting document architecture which is
sort of what about this patient or this
population led them to be in the
numerator and denominator and whether
they met the measure or not and that can
then be easily rolled up so it's just a
sort of a special case so now we've got
a standard right that has so if I'm
seeing this patient that's Trisha [ __ ]
at a transition what's the information I
need about them in the CCDA if I'm
reporting my quality measures what
information do I specifically send and
what's the Q RDA and and so we've got a
standard and the question is how do we
implement them and the other part that's
been really interesting is that because
the EHRs have been tasked to do to have
this capability they actually said the
EHR should be calculating this
electronic clinical quality measure or
you can use and approve population
management system but you've got to get
certified to basically calculate that in
so most places most of the EHRs
mentioned most of the implementations
they do it themselves and so they do
this through this health quality measure
format definition that gets implemented
and I just have to say that the National
Library medicine is helping to maintain
the concepts that are part of all those
measured definitions through the value
said authorities center the VSA see
which is sort of attached the umls
project so this is something now I use
really frequently in my work to say hey
what are the set of codes for icd-10
around CHF what are the sno-med codes
for it it's all maintained there and
updated their across all of these
quality measures really a valuable
resource for it for everyone i'll show a
picture of that so looking at the CCDA
there was a grant from O&C to
Massachusetts to say hey is on this
standard going to meet our needs for how
information exchange for the kinds of
things people need to do so the first
thing they found out is that yeah I mean
there's a bunch of elements that are
important what they did is they
basically said what are the elements you
need to do to take really good care of
this patient to add the value to get the
value from this if from this document
and so in the initial format there 175
components but they found 325 total
components that are basically needed for
the basic transition of care and then if
you're really taking someone over cat
care over a long period of time you need
even more 183 component and so
immediately it's sort of like well we
need to have a staged approach because
the initial definition of the CCD in the
CCDA is just too narrow especially they
were looking at both the definition and
then also how it was implemented so for
the implementation of at that time the
ccd CCD they said you know there's only
175 we need 483 you could add these
other elements in the infrastructure
it's it's an XML sort of extensible
infrastructure but you have to actively
do it so a lot of work to really get the
sort of core elements that are needed to
take care of the patients so you can
basically map them in without difficulty
but there's a ton of implementation work
here you can't just flip the switch and
say my CCDA is going to be useful to
everyone or I'm going to start receiving
good information from anybody you don't
know what you don't know when the
elements are missing to take care of a
patient so that's the first thing even
if we turn this on and we solved all the
privacy security issues now we have to
think very carefully about what's
missing so a lifetime's of work for
implementations in this regard some do
not some do not have CCDA templates at
this time although they sense course
ganda hl7 and they've they've I think
they've implemented a fat they've
developed most of them now I'm sorry
this is sort of a complicated slide the
only porpoise purpose of this is that
depending on what you're doing with a
patient whether you're doing a care
encounter that's shared between a
specialist a consultation request your
sort of asking somebody to help out are
you doing a big transfer of care like to
a long-term care facility it also varies
you don't need all 483 if you're just
sort of asking a specialist can you help
with the cardiology so there's work in
sort of context and setting and these
other elements and one of the things
that they looked at pretty carefully is
there's really poor definition for those
kinds of long-term care or post acute
care that's not in the home so that
they're there needs to be a lot more
help part of that's because most of them
don't have EHRs but that there's
different approaches needed for that and
they developed this clever little land
and see approach where you could sort of
share different aspects with those
settings they're working on that so a
lot of exciting work in that area that's
really nice for informatics and as a
word again comes along with that that's
the sort of things that we're doing the
other thing is that there are some
immediate value for health information
exchange VA started to do this a long
time ago saying well if you're seeing at
a VA in you know Portland Maine you
should be able to get the data in the
Portland Oregon VA you know there are
different data structures there's a lot
of decentralized development of VA's
vista and then cprs it's since she's got
centralized but they figured out a way
to map it and implement it but only
between VA sites right so then they got
hey this is great for us right because
we've got this and then EHR said hey
let's do this and so I've got a health
system in Texas charmagne name with they
use a particular EHR hie type thing it
called care everywhere basically they
say this is what we use for hie this is
the way we do this but of course you're
only exchanging between two people who
have that same EHR between the VA right
you're missing a lot of information and
what's happened is people feel good you
know I now exchange information I have
achieved you know this height but
they're really missing a lot and as you
saw in Oregon there's 97 different EHRs
although the majority of them are from
less than 10 you you start to get into
this implementation where you have to
sort of rework and i'll tell you in
portland because there's a particular
each hour that dominates people really
like the h the hie light the focus hie
that exists here and so there's a lot of
work to sort of expand beyond what your
EHR is implemented so that's so you know
early adopters are people who are
innovative might get penalized so this
is a work i do for my research you know
mostly i do research and complex care
management through care management plus
and we've gone out into quality and
quality measurement and when we started
our grants we were doing a grant saying
well can you randomize patients to
improve quality or the clinic's to
improve quality versus randomize them to
do care coordination type activities
which of those is going to reduce
hospital bed days more for complex
patients so we had to develop a whole
quality infrastructures we have about oh
just under 70 measures that we've
implemented in this and it's used
operationally but we had to do it before
there were any electronic clinical
quality measure definitions so you know
we sort of you know we were innovators
and we did this and we built nice
dashboards and you know one of the
things we learned in this is that when
we brought on clinics from different
EHRs a B and C all have different EHRs
we get this weird result you can see
that their performance of this
particular blood pressure control in
diabetes is really variable and it looks
like clinic a is really decreasing over
time like they you know are sort of
going down and it turns out the reason
for that is that there's a lot of
validation work that you need to do and
and when you know when you're mapping it
yourself you're not relying on somebody
else to do it for you you can do that so
this is the way we do it here we get
feedback from the clinics we show them
the individual data with what the
patient had what the a1c was or the
blood pressure was and then they can
tell us hey this is wrong you need to
fix this and then we can adjust our feed
when EHR is calculated for you you can't
do that you've got to collect the data
the right way the first time the way the
EHR wants you to or you miss the
so you can't adjust your feet so easily
anymore it's all sort of in the in the
EHR and we've done this with lots of
different EHR systems and each one is
sort of a novel experience in trying to
figure out the way they store the data
so they got pushed to do this all
themselves and this is my favorite graph
because basically when we started this
in 2009 nothing like this existed at all
and now it's all been developed there
were a clinical quality measures but
they weren't implemented quite to the
specificity and basically what this
shows is that EHRs are holding the
definition of the e measures and they
are producing these the quality measures
themselves they are required to produce
them through a calculation engine in
most cases I mean you you you can have a
certified engine that does it but in
most cases the EHRs doing it in
producing these reports and so it turns
out and they are producing the export
format as part of what they're required
to do so they're doing the ccda s and
the specific QR da types under that and
so because of the short time frame here
they've really had to throw this in
basically and try and get it up and
running as fast as they can so basically
EHR is now just calculating it whatever
data they have you were surprised before
by that you can imagine and I've
actually talked to Paul Tang has been on
the health information technology policy
committee in the ONC they said and we
know you're going to be surprised by
some of your quality measures when you
implement for instance meaningful use
your electronic quality measure that's
okay you know that's just reflection
you're just getting paid for reporting
for this now but a lot of places as soon
as that data is out there they say oh
I'm going to use this to judge the
quality of care you receive when your
EHR is calculating the measure it's
totally dependent on your EHR the way
they want to set it up and it's a lot of
work to try and do this the other thing
is it's very you're sort of solving a
couple puzzles first is how is my care
of this patient varying but
how do how is the EHR interpreting care
I deliver how is it taking the data I
have and I'll give a quick example of
that I want to leave some time for
questions so the first thing we found
out when we did it is the EHR wasn't
actually telling you saw in the previous
slide we showed people the what was the
hemoglobin a1c in that measure in a lot
of EHRs all their required did they meet
or did they not meet a measure for a
particular provider at a particular time
that's all you're supposed to report if
you're reporting in an aggregate that's
all you know about that is they met
evidently and literally they're not
required to store this in particular way
so you know you don't have you don't
know why they didn't nerded did or
didn't meet this measure so you're
implementing type problem-solving
detective work is a little bit harder
than it was before in that one another
one and hope Laurie enjoys this example
this has happened to us so this is a
standard Esper the drug and alcohol
screening form it's actually got some
depression screening on the top of it so
this very standard approach and John
munch here who's a family medicine with
some other colleagues basically got a
grant to advanced expert screening so
get drug and alcohol screening in place
be early adopters improve our quality as
we go in and so there's a whole bunch of
aspects of this you could see so you do
an initial risk reen this is depression
and then you do a full screen for their
second screening and then do you
actually intervene to say gosh you've
got a prop I think you know problem with
drug or alcohol have you thought about
stopping or quitting or you know which
you know this I'm not doing it well I
should model the right behavior for you
but the point is that the all the steps
are captured and the way we implemented
the measure the way they they did we got
like five we got basically sort of
components of each did you do the
initial annual screen and all the
patients you saw in primary care for
those who had a bad score who had a high
potentially concerning score did you did
you actually get more specific and give
them the full screen right
and then did you intervene did you do
the brief intervention on the people who
did that great well so we were getting
you know fifty to sixty five percent on
our sort of initial screening and moving
to full screening so we felt like we'd
really improve from 0% before and then
and then our see the CCO the state
definition of this has a different
measure which requires a billing code to
be dropped that we never use so our
score is less than 1% all of a sudden so
you know it's we were very surprised by
this so we you know these these are sort
of the lessons and so then you've got to
go back and retrofit change some way but
you've already got a process that's
working pretty well so you tell all your
clinicians stop doing that do this other
thing instead we tried that did not work
so instead we try and get the EHR to to
reflect on our position so I'm not going
to spend much time on this but I'm going
to reflect on what Lori said which is
right now most EHRs are producing the
the electronic measures in a way that
facilitates aggregate they discourage
you from doing the individual patient
data but that's where most of you know
the aggregation happens and they're
they're supposed to have the data in in
the document to tell you about what
happened so I think things will evolve
here's the value set Authority Center
which is BS I can spend this out but if
you have a umls you can go and look at
what are the definitions of the various
measures and pull up their their value
sets and look at you know what is the
core issues but so that's a really great
thing but the really down difficult
thing here at ohsu is because the EHR is
now producing these measures we've got
to create a whole set of tables to
define for ourselves what this quality
measurement means for us to help us in
our problem solving who are they seeing
who's responsible for the broad clinical
quality care are they part of a CCO
panel or are they part of a different
panel so that we can understand this and
this is just a snapshot of the
general data elements that we've had to
create on top of what the EHR crates
versus actually still being developed
now so there may be more tables as we're
going forward but you've got to do a lot
of work from the informatics tied in the
data architecture side to actually make
good use of this to use it for quality
improvement so you can't just say I'm
going to flip the switch and it'll be
good if you actually want to use it for
some of these efforts you need to do
that so those are sort of from an
informatics perspective what's the
thoughts are so maybe we'll just open it
up in these last 2 10 or so minutes for
questions for either Laurie or myself
and please press the button yes bill I'm
actually going to read a question from
our twitter feed okay by someone we know
well dick Gibson is listening and out
there and dicks question is what is the
relationship of h qm f & vs AC to
meaningful use stage 2 is a lot of work
required to morph meaningful use stage 2
reporting to these well I think there's
a lot of work you know depends on how
much time and effort you spent in
putting in your initial meaningful use
stage 1 electronic quality measures if
you really looked at that carefully
because really what this is doing the vs
vs AC just stores the concepts that are
in those quality measures the HQ and
math definition the Equality measures so
in general the approach has been for
everybody is there's a set of electronic
clinical quality measures that reporting
for Meaningful Use through your EHR your
vendor tells you here's how we suggest
you implement those and you either spend
a lot of time thinking through that
making sure you're mapping your current
workflow to what they're expecting and
doing it or you just sort of do it
quickly because it's a lot of time and
effort and for all of this the more time
you've spent looking at actually what's
going on to put the data into the EHR by
your clinician
for these clinical quality measures and
how that maps to what the EHR expects
that's going to pay off basically the
more time you think about that and think
how could I best use that data that
information to drive my workflow or how
can i adjust the EHR implementation
optimize it the better so the QR da does
bring a unique component because i think
that there's a sense that the EHR
implementation of the QR da patient
level is sort of you know it's there for
test it's but it's more in here it's
implemented they have the capability but
implementation of it probably is
something that you have to look at and
test to make sure it's good and there's
a benefit to that because then for your
ccd a definition for any health
information exchange you're gaining that
value as well because there's a lot of
overlap between them but a lot of places
don't even think about this they're just
like well I'm going to hit a switch and
send it out to them that it'll be fine
but you got to get that in and start
testing it now because you're going to
be surprised i think you know and is
it's difficult dick is a good example of
somebody who's early innovator in
quality measurement right so you're like
why are you making me adopt a broken
process and reinvent what I did and that
the point is that you know I think
there's a lot of optimization you can do
as long as you test it so hi Joe Fazio
department of pharmacy here at ohsu
pharmacy informatics so really the
question or at least the inquiry I have
around policy around data origination
you've got plenty of EHR vendors 97 but
most of them 10 as far as the
human-computer interface capturing that
information that's going to be needed
for these measures is there at least one
an effort into
creating a s a structured way of
capturing that data as opposed to a free
text or an automated way of collecting
the data during you know the EHR use
whether it's nursing pharmacy or the
provider if not our interface is being
designed in a way that it would be
easier for the individual using the
system to enter that information and I
guess for a policy from the provider
side what are we going to do to
encourage that information to be
consistently entered into the system so
that we're not reporting on a 40-percent
null for a particular field yeah I think
that's a great question I it so in
general all of your my answer to all of
your questions is this is sort of the
heart of informatics and related
disciplines to look into this issue and
now you know sort of the value we could
potentially add by looking at the
workflow and the data as it centered in
the structured data I mean experts a
particularly good one I think because
it's a lot of questionnaires and data
that might just be in the note did you
screen them yes or no follow screening
which is a new Meaningful Use measure
used in some primary care improvement
projects there's another one where
people would say ice cream them for
Paul's and put it in free text and the
question you know sort of can we develop
a set of best practices around the way
you do that because there's a ton of
reworking from what we do now to what
we're doing later and how do we feed
that back into the system so they
realize where the error is occurring I
think you're really hitting that the
problem solving that we have to do the
biggest challenge I don't know if Laura
you thought about this is you sort of
feel like well I'm already doing this
right I'm taking great care of my
patients but all of a sudden it's not
reflect any more it's a total surprise
and then get a little depressed and you
say gosh I put all this great work into
it but you know that there's so much
opportunity
that comes along with that because we're
shifting the way we think about
encouraging people to do certain things
in health care through our incentives
through just reporting those if you have
a so I can respond a little bit too in
is your mic on the as David mentioned
the collection I kind of think of it
it's multi stuff but there's two main
steps where we're in programs urban
problems one is the technology and
coming up with standards for how to
transfer and the data and then the other
step is the workflows which I think
you're alluding to so what happens is um
early on I I know of some states where
they they put together this great system
for collecting the data they looked at
it and it was almost all nulls because
the the practices weren't putting
anything in a structured field so on
some of the TA prohm resources that
we're talking about providing from the
state is to help both in the technology
side but then also in the workflow side
so how and in some ways also i think
providers are going to need support from
entities like the CCOs to build and
develop workflows in order to make so
the CCOs can get their payments so there
has to be some sort of collaboration and
and probably on incentives for providers
to do it right so I guess by my
summation of this would be our challenge
is to I guess design ways to collect the
information without getting in the way
of patient care now you know the
ubiquitous computing not being a barrier
between the provider and the patient yes
right I think that's right on that
there's a lot of work trying to
understand how do we collect this more
easily more efficiently because as the
number of standards increase so to do
the costs of collecting the information
so we got to figure that out and memoria
talked about one that's a huge cost
which is just chart review right so
we're moving away from a big cost but
are we just pushing that
cost unto other people as they're
collecting the data and we don't want to
do that we want to be efficient in our
collection we're a little bit short in
time I don't know if yeah maybe if we
have one more question or for Laurie and
myself I'm just curious is there
anywhere in Oregon where the
transformation to electronic health
record reporting has is working right
now I guess it would I need to know more
about what you mean by working i think
that um David there are programs that
are doing it but I'm not in any
coordinated fashion so for example on in
Rogue Valley area that that particular
CCO has a nhie within just their network
and so they they move data around pretty
well I think but there are kind of nodes
in the region where it works pretty well
and it's not all connected and I don't
know what no I think that's that's good
there's there's these little points of
light that that exists where they're
sharing data but there's I mean it's a
chicken and egg problem right there we
don't have to submit the individual
patient data right yet although that is
changing rapidly that that there has
been some you know there are quality
measure initiatives that have been going
on federally in other places that are
clinical quality manager like PQRS and
various forms of that system where
people have been submitting this and a
lot of the places you submit it I which
issues and it's all of those under there
cheaper but there's not a unified
standard so every one of those projects
feels like a separate initiative it
doesn't feel comprehensive probably in
the way that you mean that it's working
that you're just like oh you want my
quality measures for this here you go
right and subset the patient's no
problem that is not that kind of it's
sort of well only on the
patience and for this reason we got a
slightly different definition you can't
use this so I think that you know the
more the standards are the more people
will be ready to adapt to it but you
know we've got this problem where they
haven't been in place very long and so
we need to adjust to that okay thank you
so much we can stay around for a little
bit appreciate